you know today women make up about half
our workforce
but they still make 77 cents for every
dollar a man earns
that is wrong
and in 2014 it's an embarrassment
women deserve equal pay for equal work
she deserves to have a baby without
sacrificing her job
a mother deserves a day off
to care for a sick child or a sick
parent without running into hardship
and you know what a father does too
it is time to do away with workplace
policies that belong in a madman episode
this year let's all come together
congress the white house
businesses from wall street to main
street to give every woman the
opportunity she deserves because i
believe when women succeed america
succeeds
now
women hold a majority of lower wage
jobs but they're not the only ones
stifled by stagnant wages
americans understand that some people
will earn more money than others and we
don't resent those who by virtue of
their efforts achieve incredible success
that's what america is all about
but americans overwhelmingly agree
that no one who works full-time
should ever have to raise a family in
poverty
in the years since i asked this congress
to raise the minimum wage
five states have passed laws to raise
theirs
many businesses have done it on their
own
nick schutt is here today
with his boss john serrano
john's an owner of punch pizza in
minneapolis
and nick helps make the dough
only now he makes more of it
john just gave his employees a raise to
10 bucks an hour and that's a decision
that has eased their financial stress
and boosted their morale
tonight i ask more of america's business
leaders to follow john's lead
do what you can to raise your employees
wages
it's good for the economy it's good for
america
to every mayor
governor
state legislator in america i say you
don't have to wait for congress to act
americans will support you if you take
this on
and as a chief executive i intend to
lead by example
profitable corporations like costco
see higher wages as the smart way to
boost productivity
and reduce turnover
we should too in the coming weeks i will
issue an executive order requiring
federal contractors to pay their
federally funded employees a fair wage
of at least 10 dollars and 10 cents an
hour because if you cook our troops
meals or wash their dishes you should
not have to live in poverty
of course
to reach millions more
congress does need to get on board
today the federal minimum wage is worth
about 20 percent less
than it was when ronald reagan first
stood here
and tom harkin and
george miller have a bill to fix that by
lifting the minimum wage to
ten dollars and ten cents it's easy to
remember ten ten
this will help families
it'll give businesses customers with
more money to spend
it does not involve any new bureaucratic
program
so join the rest of the country
say yes
give america a raise
give him a race